we've been parasitized by so much
vocalism
that now companies have in many cases
lost focus of their main mission
how does a woman respond to infidelity
oftentimes people who hate evolutionary
theory
will get upset because they think that
if you explain something scientifically
this means that you are justifying it or
condoning it a lot of the activists
will argue heterosexuality is learned
whereas homosexuality is innate now that
is insane
what infectious ideas today do you feel
have are creating a lot of momentum
most people are cognitive misers meaning
that they are intellectually lazy
if i want to truly find out whether the
democrats were
the racist ones or not well that's going
to have to force me to actually do some
work why don't i just believe
uncle biden who tells me that no it's
the republicans that are the kkk white
supremacist
and that's good enough for me oftentimes
what people say in their
imbecilic myopic way they think that the
attack on freedom
only comes from the government the
greatest danger comes from
creating a society where we will
self-censor
[Music]
so gang i want to i want to prepare you
for this because get ready to have a
mental workout in the next 60 to 90
minutes with my guest today god sod
who is written many books now let me
just kind of give you a background
professor
evolutionary behavioral scientist author
wrote a book which i love
the consuming instinct what juicy
burgers ferraris pornography
and gift giving reveals about human
nature which we'll get into as well as
this recent book that just came out
uh october 6th of 2020 uh
last year the parasitic mind how
infectious ideas are killing
common sense uh and then we'll talk a
critical race theory we're probably
gonna get into identity politics and
we'll get into a few other topics but
god thank you so much for making time to
for being a guest on entertainment
oh thank you so much patrick what a
pleasure to be with you when i announced
that
i was coming on your show i got a lot of
excitement i must
shamefully admit that i wasn't very
familiar with your show
now i've corrected that mistake well i'm
glad to have you our audience is also
very excited to
uh hear from you so let's let's get
right into it if you don't mind for some
of the folks that maybe don't know you
they haven't seen your content you got
tens of millions of views online but for
those that don't know would you mind
taking a minute and giving us your
background
sure so i mean my personal background or
professional whatever well personal
where are you from and then professional
yeah so personal
i was born in beirut lebanon in the 60s
we were part of the last
group of lebanese jews who had
steadfastly refused to
read the signs of the looming dangers
and so we were in lebanon in the mid 70s
when the
lebanese civil war broke out we were
there the first year
all all future butchering is always
measured against the benchmark of how
brutal the lebanese civil war was
and i could tell you as an 11 year old
child i could attest to how brutal it
was
we were able luckily to escape after
that first year the war moved to
montreal canada
and that's where my adventure in the
west began
professionally my scientific work is at
the intersection of evolutionary biology
and evolutionary psychology and consumer
behavior so i look at
what are the fundamental biological
drivers that make us the consumers that
we are but of course i define
consumption very broadly it's not just
consuming coca-cola
and posting pictures on instagram we
consume religion we consume friendships
we consume
uh you know all literature and so
everything is consumatory i look at the
biological underpinnings of that
consumatory nature
what what inspired you and what was what
got you to say i want to learn more
about this stuff oh yeah thank you great
question so first semester as a doctoral
student
at cornell university 1990 i can't
believe that it's almost
well it's more than 30 years ago uh i
taken a course in advanced social
psychology course with a professor by
the name of dennis regan
and about halfway through the course he
assigned the book called homicide
which was a book looking at patterns of
criminality
from an evolutionary perspective and so
i can give you a few examples if you'd
like but
that's when i was bitten by the by the
bug so for example if i told you patrick
let's see if you can guess this let's
see if you are a budding evolutionary
psychologist
if i told you what is the number one
predictor
of all possible predictors that can help
us understand
whether a child is going to be abused so
for example you could say
if he's born on the wrong side of the
tracks so give me your best
possible predictor and then i'll give
you the correct evolutionary one
so that you get a sense of how powerful
evolutionary thinking is
and understanding human rights number
one predictor a lack of father figure
i mean that's a great one and i'm sure
it has an effect but i'll just jump to
the actual
answer the number one predictor is if
there is
a step parent in the house
uh and the idea being that humans are a
biparental species meaning both men and
women invest heavily in their children
and therefore most people whether they
do it consciously or not
are going to exhibit differential
investment
in their biological children and their
step children so for example if you
think about
uh cinderella well the story of
cinderella is rooted in evolutionary
principles right it's the evil
stepmother but she's only evil to the
step-daughter she's not
she's not evil dispositionally also to
her biological children
and there are some very clear biological
reasons why
people would exhibit that pension to to
be less investing in their step children
i'll give you one other quick example
who who is the number one most dangerous
person in a woman's life irrespective of
which culture she comes from
well it turns out not surprisingly it's
not the guy who's hiding in the tree
you know a serial killer it's usually
her long-term partner her male partner
who typically when he when he is
triggered into a homicidal rage
is because of either realized or
suspected infidelity now why would men
be so
triggered by that possibility because
since we are a biparental species
i don't want to spend 18 20 25 years
raising the kid of the sexy gardener who
used to come and
you know trim our bushes therefore i
become
when i say i i mean prototypical male
both you and i patrick are descendants
of ancestors who really cared that their
women
hopefully don't stray so because of
paternity uncertainty men have evolved
the
cognitive emotional and behavioral
patterns
that create sexual territoriality and so
when i
saw the explanatory power of
evolutionary thinking
i had my aha moment so i thought i would
apply evolution to study consumer
behavior
yeah that that's fascinating when you're
talking about that so let's go to the
first book because i mean i got some
questions for you
just in regards to your first book and
then we'll get into the second one as
well
so the consuming instinct uh
what juicy burgers ferrari's pornography
and gift
giving reveal about human nature when
you wrote this
ten years ago exactly 10 years ago last
month june of 2011 which has been
translated to
korean and turkish interesting to have
been translated into korean and turkish
uh what's the book about and one can you
tell us what can you tell us about the
consuming instinct
about juicy burgers ferraris pornography
and gift giving
right so the reason why i chose those
four examples there's a backstory to it
so i'll explain in a second but
apparently speaking
the book is basically arguing contrary
to all of the social sciences which
presume that what makes us different
from other animals
is that we transcend our biology right
so typically social scientists think
well sure
evolution explains the behavior of the
mosquito and your dog and the giraffe
but don't you dare dr sat apply the same
principles to explain human behavior let
alone consumer behavior
well that's completely silly i mean when
i put on my hat as a consumer
my hormones don't cease to matter my
biology doesn't cease to matter so in a
very general way what the consuming
instinct is about
is how to apply biological thinking
to understand why we do the things that
we do when we put on our hats as
consumers
now why did i pick juicy burgers
pornography
gift giving and so on well because i
argue that there are four
fundamental darwinian modules that drive
our behavior
there is the survival module right so
everything that's related to our
survival instinct
so the juicy burger example speaks to
that because
we've evolved the gustatory preferences
to prefer
some juicy manifestation rather than raw
celery right
patrick and i might disagree about the
type of fatty foods we prefer i might
prefer a juicy steak
you may prefer a you know fatty
chocolate mousse
but we both probably prefer some fatty
food over
you know raw carrots precisely because
your ancestors of mine evolved in an
environment of caloric scarcity caloric
uncertainty
therefore our taste buds have evolved to
deal with that evolutionary problem
so that's juicy burgers pornography
refers to the sega module which is
reproduction so
many of the things that you and i do and
everyone else does
is precisely linked to the fact that we
are a sexually reproducing species so
in the same way that the peacock's tale
evolved so that he can impress the
peahens into saying look despite the
fact that i've got this very burdensome
tale
i'm still alive you should pick me i'm
the right mate for you
well in the human context my maserati
becomes
my peacock's tale so that explains
uh a lot of the you know and the reason
why we're attracted to pornography
is because it titillates our
computational systems in our brain
for sexual variety you mean i can get on
the internet now
and there are 10 000 beautiful nubile
women that are ready to
quote mate with me virtually well it's
very easy for them the brain to be
hijacked by this
alluring visual stimulus then the other
two
basically refer to two other modules kin
selection
explain why would i ever jump into the
river to save three brothers well
the reason would be because my three
brothers on average share half their
genes with me so if i jump into the
river and save them and even if i die
it makes perfect evolutionary sense to
do so so a lot of
gift-giving rituals that you and i
engage in with one another if let's say
you're my brother
speak to that kin-based altruism and
then finally
reciprocal altruism refers to well okay
i would jump into the river to save my
three brothers but why would i jump into
the river to save patrick
he's not my brother i mean my literal
genetic brother
but in this case maybe patrick is a very
good friend
and he will reciprocate today he's
drowning in the river
but tomorrow he might reciprocate and
protect me
if if you know if i come under under
harm so what i basically argue is that
much of what we do as consumers can be
traced back to one of those four key
darwinian modules and hence that
subtitle i hope it wasn't too
long-winded
i love that i love that so you know i
don't know if you've heard probably
you've heard this question
you're on a boat you got three people on
you can only save one
it's your mom your child or your
wife who do you save have you looked
this one up or no i've used the case
it's funny that you say this because
actually there is an exact same story to
the guy
the evolutionary scientist who was
developing that framework
it was based on you know i would jump
into the river to save four brothers so
so who would i save i guess i'd have to
do the evolutionary calculus well it
would depend
on whether you asked me this when i got
married if i'm 22 years old
or if my wife is post menopausal right
because
the reproductive sorry it's gonna sound
cow
the reproductive benefits of saving her
depends on where she is in her
reproductive window so it's a
complicated story but the fact that you
ask this
exactly speaks to the type of
evolutionary calculus calculations that
we go through
so so it depends on what phase of your
life you're in so
earlier on it would be your wife later
on and maybe your kid
exactly and by the way your kid carries
more weight for you or less
depending on how old they are so for
example in societies
where they have practice infanticide
infanticide is the
recurrent killing of children they
usually will kill
the last born because the last born so
if i've already invested 17 years in
raising a child
right and they are about to under
enter the reproductive window of their
life trajectory
then i don't want to kill them right
because i mean
don't forget that i also extend my genes
through
my children having children right
because when my children have children
i am linked to them one quarter of their
genes right so this is called inclusive
fitness
so i can i could propagate my genes
either directly
i have children or by investing in my
kin
and therefore in cultures where you have
infanticide
you and typically the reason why you
have infanticide is because you realize
that
you don't have the necessary resources
to see them through to maturation
and so you make the very cold
calculation of ending if you want their
life
well you do so if they're two months old
you don't do it to a 17 year old who's
about to be reproductively viable
themselves
yeah so when i asked this question of
other people they by the way this was an
interview question so
and it was a you know trying to figure
out where a person stood and it would
many times give a
cultural answer because you know latinos
maybe they would
choose their mom because the connection
with mom you know americans
would choose their you know wife and you
have you know
a different asian that would choose
their child because it's future you know
it's very interesting
but it definitely always starts a uh
conversation about what direction to go
with this so let's
let's go back to what you were go ahead
so forgive me for interrupting your
patrick because what you just said
has such a an implication for a segway
uh yes you're right that there are
cultural differences but underneath
these cultural differences there are
some
consistent human universals so speaking
about children
so when a child is born irrespective of
which culture you come from
typically people will say oh my god the
child looks
exactly like the father and you're much
more likely to say so
if you are from the mother's family
because you're trying
to convince the mother's family that she
didn't stray
from the relationship oh my
so since you went over there okay
infidelity men infidelity women
you know uh uh how does man respond to
it differently than a woman response to
infidelity
great question so there's some fantastic
research that was done
uh back in the early 1990s where they
asked men and women to imagine
their partner either engaging in sexual
infidelity
or romantic infidelity romantic and
fidelity
your husband always has lunch with this
wonderful colleague of his they share
their dreams she understands his humor
so there's no sex it's all platonic
but there's an emotional bond that is
forming well guess what happens
men respond much more harshly to sexual
infidelity
women respond a lot more harshly to
emotional infidelity
why because again men are responding to
the threat of paternity uncertainty
women are responding to the threat of
you
removing your investment from the
relationship and it turns out
that it's a much bigger predictor of me
packing my bags and leaving you if i
develop an emotional bond with
another woman rather than just a sexual
dalliance this is why
men oftentimes in a very uh
clumsy way when they are caught cheating
one time at a conference at
somewhere they'll say she meant nothing
to me it was a one-time thing
what they are effectively doing is
speaking to that evolutionary concern
which is
i could completely decouple my
investment in you
from the fact that i just had a desire
for sexual variety
now by the way when i explain these
things oftentimes people who hate
evolutionary think
theory will get upset because they think
that if you explain something
scientifically
this means that you are justifying it or
condoning it and i'm
of course doing no such thing right if
you're studying cancer
that doesn't mean that you are for
cancer it doesn't mean that you are
justifying and condoning cancer it means
that you're studying cancer
so if you want to understand all sorts
of ugly things that people do you have
to study them properly and that's why i
love evolution so much
what what a thing to study infidelity on
how women respond to it versus men so
you know this is a channel a lot of our
audience they're entrepreneurs business
owners sales you know they're executives
they're running now obviously we've got
bodybuilders you know we have
mob we have politics we have different
things that we cover but specifically
it's business
marketing so you just said consuming
instinct what juicy burgers ferraris
pornography and gift giving reveals
about human nature right so
a company's built their brand on having
a certain set of audience that's who
they draw let's just say
pick a product you know if you got fox
news republicans
cnn democrats msnbc far left
espn sports you know you go to
yahoo horoscope cert not anyways you go
to all these different places
how do you see this because a company as
big
victoria's secret who's known who their
customers for the longest time
and who buys their stuff who to appeal
to
how do you view and justify a company
that big with a ceo to say
look we're going to go in a completely
different direction we're not going to
have our
you know the the what do you call it
they're angels anymore that you see and
all this stuff
the girls now we're going to go we're
going to get activists we're going to go
on a completely different angle
we're not going to go to that route how
do you justify to say yeah they're doing
the right thing they're going the right
direction versus saying they're about to
pay a price for it
well they are going to pray they are
going to pay a price for it and
so one of the things that i do in my say
when i'm teaching mba classes
and i'm doing all this evolutionary
stuff i i want to kind of
assuage the the worry of my students
because they feel as though they've
wrongly fallen into the wrong class some
biology class rather than some mba
course of consumer behavior
and i tell them you know be patient
because it's all going to come
together i'm teaching you now the
universal
explanations for human behavior but then
i will give you some very practical
implications
in in marketing so and so to address
your question let me give one such
example
so if you look at romance novels romance
novels are almost
exclusively read by women all around the
world there is
there's not a single culture where that
phenomenon is reversed
so if i want to study female
preferences i could look at the
archetype of the male hero in a romance
novel
to see what what is it that women
fantasize about when they are consuming
such a product and it turns out that
it's always the exact same guy it's as
if it's plagiarized
across every single romance novel that's
ever been written patrick's what is he
he's tall he is socially dominant he is
a count
meaning a prince and a neurosurgeon he
is
reckless and a risk taker he wrestles
alligators on his six-pack but he could
only be tamed by the love of this one
good good woman
i just shaved i just saved you the
the the heartache or or the effort of
having to read every romance novel
that's ever been written i should have
never had 50 shades of gray
exactly so now let's so that's my next
point now
is going to bring home the the question
that you asked
so a few years ago a company i don't
remember their name uh was a progressive
company they wanted to create a new line
of romance novels
that extricated themselves from this
archetypal view of the
toxic masculine man and so they created
a new line
where the guy you know is sensitive he
cries all the time he sucks his thumb he
watches bridget jones diary
well guess what happened the consumers
in this case called
women said sorry not interested that's
not what i fantasize about
when i'm trying to escape in a romance
novel so if you do
things as a company that violate
fundamental tenets of human nature the
market has a very clever way of
correcting your
misconceptions so i always tell my
students
ultimately a good marketer is one who
understands human nature whether they've
taken my courses or not so that's the
bottom line
it's interesting you say that so i it
took me five i took five years to write
a
fiction book okay it's a young adult's
fiction book
and it's you know we brought a lot of
the consultants in we went through a lot
of different revisions back and forth
and
once we got to sitting down with the
publisher and the publisher said
your book has to be appealing to women
young adults the audience who reads
young adults
70 are going to be this age to this age
if you can appeal to them
you're going to be able to get a book
that's going to sell if you don't it's
not going to work out so
even the the marketers the sellers the
publishers sit there and say yeah we're
not interested in that it's not a
business model that's going to work
so to you based on what you're saying
right now because here's how i process
it
i process it as if you go read any of
the old marketing books you know which
ones i'm talking about you know there's
a
kellogg and you know you go through some
of these that everyone reads at all mba
you know business schools
you know you'll see certain approaches
on how to get colors
story marketing pitch all that stuff but
it looks like many of these companies
are getting away maybe not all of them a
lot of them are getting away from sex
drugs rock and roll you know
that whole thing the sex drugs and rock
and roll still sell today
i mean they do certainly the sex part so
for example if i'm trying to sell beauty
products
uh putting a per an endorser who has
facial symmetry
is going to work because facial symmetry
is a marker of good phenotypic quality
it means that you haven't been exposed
right so to be beautiful is to be
symmetric so
whether i am selling a cosmetic line in
romania or bolivia or nigeria
people in all those countries
irrespective of the race they come from
irrespective of the ethnic group and so
on
they're all going to agree as to who is
beautiful i think the problem and maybe
that's what you're alluding to
is that now we've been parasitized to
use a term from my
latest book we've been parasitized by so
much walkism
that now companies have in many cases
lost focus of their main mission
right now it is no longer enough to
provide consumers with a product that
they need without harming some third
party let's say the environment
now i need to appear as though i am
socially engaged that i am fighting
against
social injustice think of the gillette
ad a few years ago i don't know if you
remember it patrick where they
were sort of down talking to all ma men
stop being toxic masculine men well
i don't i don't want gillette razor
company
to be lecturing me and patronizing me
about how to be a better man why don't
you shut your mouth and just
sell me a good uh you know razor and
i'll worry about demoralizing at home so
in my view i think it's a mistake for
companies to be engaging in all of this
blue haired uh
walkism why do people fall for it though
i mean you look at so many people
like for example when nike announced
they're going with kaepernick you know
the year and a half ago two years ago i
don't know if you remember that well
okay here's the direction we're gonna be
going
and they did and they said i will never
buy another nike ever again
and then nike just announces we have our
biggest quarterly profits you know
and then the other side says they were
right
the marketing team knew what they were
talking about and folks are like well i
guess we didn't know what we were
talking about so once they show the data
some people are saying it's kind of good
to take a position today versus before a
lot of people played it neutral
um as as you were speaking i brought out
a prop let me explain what it is it's a
memory stick
but for a second pretend that it is the
cork of a wine bottle okay
in arabic there's an expression that
says
getting drunk simply by smelling the
cork bottle which means what basically
it means that
i am so weak that it doesn't take me
just to drink the whole bottle to get
drunk i just need to take a whiff of the
cork bottle
and i'm already dizzy with drunkenness
right so
kaepernick is exactly that right for
most people who are
too imbecilic to kind of understand the
greater issues
he just seems as though he's fighting
for justice so
these are the people who are getting
drunk by the smell of the cork but for
most people i think and there's actually
been a study
that has tried to look at does walkism
work in terms of the share that you know
does it doesn't improve
you know increase uh the share price of
the company
and the results certainly don't support
that that that being woke becoming more
blue-haired in your engagement
doesn't lead to higher share prices so
yes some people will succumb to that
kind of uh
virtue signaling but i think most
consumers are smart enough
to understand when it's just empty
virtuous signal
is is the whole idea about you know who
cares about controversy as long as
people are talking about it you'll win
it you know the whole thing about
you know negative media attention is it
still you know marketing is marketing
doesn't matter whether it's positive or
negative do you
agree and uh agree with that i mean yes
in the sense that we to bring it back to
evolution we've evolved
to pay a lot more attention to negative
information
than to positive one and precise for
obvious
you know evolutionary adaptive reasons
and so once you
have some controversy that is laden with
some negativity
even if it's false by the way you've
probably heard the old uh
story about uh a falsehood can travel 10
times around the world before it is you
know corrected
exactly right and so so yes i do believe
that controversy works by the way i know
a lot of colleagues of mine
who were completely obscure in academia
i mean they
they were they never published anything
they they were hardly at good schools
they were very very obscure d-level
academics
who then faced some controversy and
suddenly were catapulted to the front
lines
uh and so yes i completely agree that
controversy sells
i mean look at jordan peterson right
i don't i wouldn't put him in the d-list
by the way he's not he's not a d-list no
no we
he's the only guy we've ever had on four
times jordan peterson's the only
guy we've interviewed four different
times and i had him at our event
so happy offended that you've invited
him four times before going to dr sad
for the first time
one could be offended but i should be
magnanimous and not be offended as an
evolutionary behavioral scientist
today we're gonna find out if we can
invite you back for a second time which
is
at this pace we're going you're
definitely being invited back but oh
yes but you know we had them on we had
them at an event two years ago i had
president bush kobe bryant jordan
peterson billy being at an event with
seven thousand people in mgm
and i interviewed jordan peterson that
was exactly a month before he went away
and he was kind of dealing with his own
personal issues but look at jordan
peterson he faces off against what the
university wanted to do
he comes out and says this the stand i'm
taking boom next you know he takes off
you know look at trump comes out and
says hey uh if you remember the
2015-2016
republican side day one everybody
thought scott walker
and jeb bush were going to win it i
don't know if you remember scott walker
was like
the main wisconsin superstar this is
presidential jeb bush they 140 million
dollars trump comes out and says
they're sending their criminals rapists
drugs all this other stuff and next you
know he takes off
so you know there's a there's a bit of
it where you're noticing that become a
even in boxing today look at the paul
brothers look at logan and jake paul
how they're using controversy to bring
eyeballs to themselves
and how effective it is more than just
controversy if i if i may interject
patrick
i think people respect those who are not
fence sitters i always remind people
don't be a fence sitter
right if if i were to ask you who are
the top five people that you admire most
in the world
i'm willing to bet none of them are
fence sitters why because it takes
courage to take positions no questions
whether you like
trump or not he's not a fence sitter
whether you like jordan peterson or not
he's a principled man whether you like
or not got sad
i go after everything and everybody i
don't care i don't modulate the pursuit
of truth
to not hurt someone's feeling that's why
in chapter eight and i guess we'll talk
about it later in chapter eight of my
latest book
i talk about activate your inner honey
badger why do i say that because the
honey badger
is an animal the size of a small dog
and yet it is more you know ferocious
it's so ferocious that it could
withstand the attack of six adult lions
why does it do it because it's
intimidating as hell so be a honey
badger
so so as an evolutionary behavioral
scientist
you're looking at ways we behave
respond marketing a lot of the things
that you covered here yourself
and you speak to a lot of business
schools to a lot of you know folks who
are trying to get their mbas
what are your rules i've read a lot of
books on marketing people have different
kind of angles on how to take it how not
to take it
what what have you noticed being the
formula great marketers have used
historically what is it
yeah i mean there are there are several
so let me give you one that
of continues what i was talking about
earlier about understanding human nature
if you're a social scientist you
typically believe that the human mind
we are born tabula rasa empty minds and
it is only socialization
that makes you who you are so why do men
prefer certain types of women
uh well it's because they learned it
from oprah and elle magazine
why do women prefer certain types of
guys oh it's because they saw it in
hollywood
so that perspective presumes that the
mind of the consumer is infinitely
malleable
i as the smart company can get the
consumer to
want and like anything that i teach them
to want and like
and i think that is a grossly incorrect
position
because the genes as e.o wilson the
harvard
biologist said the genes always hold
culture
on a leash so in other words culture can
can cause you and i
to have slightly different food
preferences
but across all cultures people prefer
more rich food than raw cal
you know raw celery so you if you are a
marketer you always have
to recognize the interplay between
culture
and genes and if you create products
that are antithetical
to human nature the market will quickly
let you know
that you are an idiot so let me give you
another example
uh mcdonald's and all of the other
companies
for fast food companies that have done
well around the world they've done well
not because they have justin timberlake
singing a jingle
although that certainly helps because it
creates top of mind awareness
but they've done very well because they
offer something to my gustatory
preferences
that i don't need to be taught to prefer
i don't need to teach my young child
that fatty juicy french fries
is something that they should respond
positively to
here's a here's a thought experiment i
could give you 10 billion dollar
advertising budget
to sell you grass juice at mcdonald's
and all of the celebrity endorsers to
promote it and it's never going to take
off
because my gustatory preferences and
yours don't like
raw grass juice so the main lesson
from anything that i teach in my mba
courses is
there is no way to understand the
consumer without an understanding of the
fundamental drivers
that drive consumer behavior and that's
rooted in our biology
it's not rooted in culture it's not
rooted in religion it's not rooted in
oprah
okay so so fantastic so let's go a
little bit deeper with that
so how much of what i like what you like
is what you like versus what's being
sold to us for example let me go a
little deeper
no matter how many skinny models i saw
on calvin klein
i was never turned on by right you know
what i'm saying so i saw
me this is what you're supposed to look
like like a zoolander looking you're
you know looking like it they never did
nothing to me i was almost like can i
get you a double whopper right now go
eat a big mac please eat some pizza and
put some weight on
you're 95 pounds you look like you're
about to break if i even touch you like
i'm worried about touching here right
so how much of it is
us believing in the dream that's being
sold from media
from politicians from our clergy from
our parents where
you know kids parents tell them you know
a good man is somebody who believes in
god and lives a godly life a good man is
somebody that
takes care of themselves honey you have
to look sexy put on the right makeup or
you know you got to go serve the
military because it's this you got to
have you got to work hard you know
you got to really work hard all these
things that we go through organize
clean athlete my dad loves football i'm
going to go be a football player to make
him proud
how much of it is the marketing being
done around us by media tv parents
military all that stuff and how much of
it is actually us yeah i mean great so
if i were to rephrase your your question
i would say you're in in a sense if i
distill it it's you're asking about the
nature versus nurture
issue right how much of who we are is
due to nature genes
how much of it is due to nurture you
know all the things that you mentioned
well and the best way for me to answer
that i'm not trying to do a cop-out
answer it's it's really the true
scientific answer
so i'm going to use a metaphor here so
if you take
all of the ingredients of a cake you
take the butter you take the eggs
you take the flour you take the baking
soda
each of those ingredients are separate
right before i bake the cake once i bake
the cake
and now i show you the final cake if i
were to tell you
patrick please point to the eggs you
couldn't it's an inextricable mix
patrick please point to the sugar
so we are that cake we are an
inextricable
melange mix of our genes and our
environments now
depending on the phenomenon you ask me
about it might tilt more towards nature
or nurture my height is driven a lot
more by my nature
than my nurture no amount of hugging and
coddling by my parents
would have turned me into a six foot six
basketball player
so it depends so so the best answer i
can give you is it depends
some things are almost exclusively
nature some
are largely due to nurture but most are
somewhere in the middle
i i hope that i've given you a
satisfactory answer yeah
maybe let me go a little bit deeper with
that and and i know i know that
answering up kind of a
you know a word the nature and we'll
debate that all the time
are entrepreneurs born are they made and
what kind of i'm going a little bit
deeper than that so
for example um
you know i sit there and i market the
idea of
being gay and lesbian to you
on tv it was getting i don't know
point two percent of tv or media was
showing
what a gay character is or commercials
having gay
lesbian all that stuff right and today
it's it's widely accepted left and right
it's no longer like a
thing where of you know trump was asked
on his campaign hey
so what do you think about the lgbt it's
a lot what do you want to do that's what
let's go next topic and it's just kind
of moved on no one's debating it anymore
except from the far extreme
conservatives you know more clergy based
you know faith-based republicans
but if i if i increase that from point
one percent to one percent to two
percent to five percent of coverage on
tv to ten percent
and it's now my face does it influence
me
as a kid thinking you know maybe i am
gay maybe i am lesbian maybe i know
does it influence that at all no so i
think what it would do if we if we take
that specific example you're giving what
the
changes in culture will do is that it
might
normalize the existence of
homosexuality such that we no longer
consider it a taboo
right so through those interventions
we change the cultural norms that allow
us to now
view same-sex couple as you know just
who cares i can just
you know without batting an eye but it's
not
going to affect my underlying sexual
preferences
which are innate right but interestingly
by the way a lot of the activists now
look look how silly this can get a lot
of the activists
will argue that heterosexuality
is learned whereas homosexuality is
innate
now that is insane we are a sexually
reproducing species
so you would think that for a sexually
reproducing species the default value
would be heterosexuality but apparently
i'm just a dumb
evolutionary behavioral scientist well i
want to show you this i this literally
just came up while i'm talking to i just
searched it on google so
let me try to share screen and just kind
of show this to you i want to hear your
thoughts on this so this is from gallup
so gallup shows let me know if you can
see it i can see yeah go ahead
okay so gallup shows that since 2012
till today american self-identification
as
lgbt went from three and a half percent
to three six three seven
three nine now five point six percent
identify as
lgbt up two percent from just eight
years ago to 2020.
so and gallup is pretty center you know
it's not left or it's right
uh where you know like for example maybe
i'll take a different angle with this i
don't have to go necessarily to this
let's take another one
i'm speaking at a conference they invite
me to speak
group of pastors hey marketing they
wanted me to talk specifically on the
marketing side
hey why is you know money being given to
churches down
christian not denomination not
necessarily under the nominee
specifically non-denomination
why is it down you know these young
people just don't get it anymore
i said you know what go to mormon's
youtube channel
so if you go to mormon's youtube channel
mormonism is up okay
you go to a bunch of churches they're up
non-denomination is low
okay why is that what are you guys doing
that you weren't doing before right okay
here's another one for you the argument
of atheists
that argument wasn't that high 50 years
ago
okay we had it don't get me wrong of
course we've we've had it for a long
time this isn't a new thing
thomas jefferson had an element of
debating the existence of god so it's
not a new thing i'm not sitting here
telling you everybody always believed in
god
but you'll hear a lot of people say
things like this you know i used to be a
jew
i used to believe in all this other
stuff and i used to be catholic i used
to be a christian
but listen we're much smarter today you
know we know let's face it there is no
god what are you talking about it's been
proven all this other stuff
is that because we're smarter or is that
because
the people on tv and social talking
about that god doesn't exist has
increased the percentage of that message
being given where people are starting to
say
you know what maybe you're right god
doesn't exist i'm trying to see how much
of that's being influenced from media
i think it's several factors whether it
be the lgbtq data that you shared from
gallup or whether it be the atheism
example that you gave
so one possibility is by creating
a quote safer environment for someone to
truly identify as an atheist when in the
past it was difficult for me to do so
or to truly identify as a member of the
lgbtq
community whereas earlier i would have
been ostracized by my family and kicked
out of my small
town in the southern usa then those
those patterns go up not so much because
they are now more lgbtq people but
because people are more comfortable
admitting to who they are so that's one
possibility
but there's a slightly more uh i mean
not sinister but
uh you know less uh clear example and
actually i had a guest on my show
it hasn't er the conversation hasn't
aired her name is abigail schreier
she wrote a book where she basically
argued
that the increase in transgender
young women so biological women who now
self-identify as male is
akin to a social contagion right in
other words in the same way that a
contagion can spread
ideas also spread and so for whatever
reason
it becomes intoxicating to be a member
of
that identifiable group so the next
question you can ask me well why would
every anybody
ever want to self-identify as a
member of a marginalized group like the
lgbtq folks people
and here actually i'm going ahead to uh
my
latest book i actually explained this
using using something called a
psychiatric
disorder called munch housing syndrome
can i take a minute or two to explain
please so in 2010 i had written a
scientific paper in a medical
journal on munchausen syndrome which is
the
mechanism whereby someone feigns a
illness so that they can garner the
empathy and sympathy that comes with
having that illness
munch house and syndrome by proxy is
even more diabolical because this is
when
you have someone under your care your
elderly parent
your pet or typically your biological
child
you harm them you physically harm them
so that you can then garner the empathy
and sympathy by proxy oh poor you
you're a parent of an ailing child so i
was trying to understand
the evolutionary reason why biological
mothers would harm their children to get
that ego stroke so now i'm gonna tie it
in with that social contagion that i
just talked about well to the extent
that it now becomes a form of victimhood
to be a member of a marginalized group
i can get my ego strokes my empathy and
sympathy
by being a member of that group you
follow now as you might imagine
abigail schreier got into a lot of
trouble
because quote she was erasing the voices
of those transgendered kids
now she wasn't saying that
transgenderism doesn't exist she wasn't
saying that we should be bigoted towards
transgenderism she was simply saying
that for some of the people they aren't
truly transgendered
they are simply succumbing to a social
contagion so to go back to finalize with
your gallup poll
i suspect that some of that uptake is
due to the social contagion effect
so the irreversible damage is the one i
think you're talking about the book
exactly right exactly so so let's go on
that let's go even deeper with that on
what you're saying so
i'll give you a story i'm in the army
i'm 18 19 years old
i love women like i can't have enough of
them like i was like you know i
i was greedy extremely greedy right and
i was a capitalist
i i wanted to experience everything and
anything i could
one day one of the guys at our unit says
i found the sickest club
but i can't tell everybody about it
because we could all be kicked out of
the army if they find out what club this
is i said what club is it's a gay club
so it's a gay club yeah but i'm telling
you it's the best club in america i'm
like it's the best club in america
where is it at it's in nashville
tennessee get out of here no one's gonna
put the best club in nashville tennessee
i'm telling you it's the best club in
nashville tennessee what's the name i
can't tell you i just have to take you
there first all right so at this point
of the game
thank god i trust this guy because he
was my workout partner
so i asked him i said listen i mean i
partied with you i've never seen you
like men he says no no you don't
i don't like men but you got to go here
with me you'll see why it's unfair
i said okay let's go so we go to the
club so we take one of our friends it's
four of us now two of our friends
by the way all of them till today uh
were in contact so we go to the club
first of all women are there with the
intention of they don't want to be
flirted they want to be left alone right
so they're kind of going they're saying
oh
gay men i love gay men because they're
this they're that so there's only a few
straight men there
we're four of them okay so the market's
on our side we're winning here right
but we go in and obviously it was
exactly what he said
it was unfair it's like the movie a
wedding crasher where the
scene where owen wilson goes to meet uh
will ferrell and wilfer's like my wheat
loaf
he says man i'm not going to weddings
anymore i'm crashing funerals you gotta
see it's like it's not even fair because
you know all this stuff anyways
now obviously there's a part of it
that's not funny but that's humor movie
you know we all watch wooden crotch it's
funny
but one of my friends a guy comes and
flirts with them
now for me it's like listen it's cool i
get along with everybody i'm very
comfortable
but i have no interest but one of the
guys comes and tells one of our friends
and he says
so you like men no i like women
he asks a simple question afterwards how
do you know
and i gotta tell you this question of
how do you know
confuse the living crap out of this guy
so we leave the place we got a one-hour
drive back it's two o'clock in the
morning we've had 20 beers in us we're
driving with you know alcohol levels
that's not appropriate at all
the entire time he's like how do i know
like what are you doing
but i pat i really don't know what do
you mean how do you how do what do you
fantasize
but here's what's crazy about it you
know what ended up happening
this guy experience just to find out if
he knows or not
that that's what he had a gay encounter
just to answer that question
just to answer that question whether he
did or not
so the part i'm going to you with this
obviously there's humor behind the story
but it wasn't humorous on the drive back
i'm just i just remember being hammered
and we're cracking up about it
but the point i'm trying to make to you
is if media
and tv social if they have this much
power
if they just put it in your mind to say
how do you know
cocaine isn't good for you how do you
know you're not a trans how do you know
you're not this how do you know you're
not that
how do you know we don't know how do you
know communism doesn't work how do you
know
how do you know how do you know you're
like maybe i don't know
maybe it is euphoric maybe it is utopian
type of a life maybe i should try
that's what i mean when i say the
marketing today the amount of influence
they have
is it really changing the way we're
wired because we're questioning stuff
about ourselves that maybe we just don't
know
i don't i i wish marketers had that much
influence
they don't uh now in your in the case of
your friend maybe he had some
you know some questions that he needed
answered but i think that if you were
asked a hundred men uh
who are you know about heterosexuals
how do you know you don't want to get
sodomized by a turkish
hairy guy how do you know they'll say
well because i don't fantasize about
that i
basically i've lit my entire internal
life of fantasy
has been rooted in fantasizing over
beyonce and not about a turkish hairy
guy
sodomizing me so so i don't think it's
that mysterious and i don't think any
marketing guy is going to convince me
to go to a gay sauna uh you know
sodomy so so i think that that's on your
friend
but i will mention something uh that is
scientifically interesting to what you
asked there is something called sexual
fluidity
and it's actually it's a it's a real
term whereby
so if you look at women they're much
more likely to be
fluid so for example a woman could be
completely
committed to being a heterosexual woman
she really prefers
men but you know in that
dorm at wellesley on that cold evening
night when
my girlfriend and i were really tight
and we started wrestling a little
lesbian session
broke out now i say that you know in a
jocular manner
but women have the capacity to be
a lot more fluid in their sexuality
whilst
completely being uh you know committed
to being heterosexual
it's much much less likely in men and
and the data the scientific data
suggests that
very few men wake up on a tuesday and
say today
i have to kind of think inside do i want
to be
clobbered by shakil o'neal or is it
going to be beyonce night
no i think i'm going shaquille very few
guys maybe your friend was one of those
but he's a unicorn i hope he doesn't see
this interview because he's going to be
upset with me i highly thought he's
going to see it but we didn't mention
his name so we no we did not so we're
safe we're saying we let's just give him
a name let's call him uh let's call him
uh
jackson is what we're gonna call him
okay so all right so
but let's go back to that let's go back
to that whether you're gonna wake up in
the morning with a fantasy about getting
clobbered by shaq i can't see that
happening with you but
let's just see somebody does wake up by
me i'm the guy in that relationship
he's the girl mrs shack
that visual is just a very strange
visual i'm going to try to take out of
my head today guys that's not a visual i
want to have with a
evolutionary behavioral scientist
hooking up with shaq
so so so let's let's get away from that
let's go to a whole different place but
specifically to that topic okay so let's
get away from the gay
and how do you know right let's go to uh
uh
the same phrase being repeated a billion
times until you're like
you know what men are dogs men are dogs
men are dogs men are dogs men are dogs
men are dogs
hoes before bros vote bros before allah
whatever so
he's like a woman all women do this all
men lie
all men like that's you hear that a
billion times you're like you know what
that's right you know men are this but
are that okay
so 1960
64 of african americans are voting
republican
1964 92 percent of african americans are
voting
democrat okay let me say that one more
time i'm sorry in 1960
64 of african americans are voting
democrats 64.
36 are voting republicans 64 voting
democrat
that's in 1960 fast forward four years
later barry goldwater
1964 92 is voting
democrat it went from 64 to 92 and it
span of four years right
so the messaging of and today by the way
the numbers that are on 88 percent
84 to 88 we're still at that same number
trumpet was a little bit lower but
you're still out around the mid 80 range
that we have today
so you hear the phrase democrats are
republican democrats are for blacks
democrats are for blacks democrats are
for blacks democrats are for blacks
democrats are for black
you go look at jews jews come to america
the rich republicans uh country clubs
didn't allow jews on right no italian no
jews no you you know you've seen that
sign god
so jews so powerful they make so much
money why are they democrats
most of their beliefs is conservative
but why are they democrats because
democrats are for jews democrats are for
jews democrats are for jews
i'm armenian your wife is lebanese
armenian i'm armenian assyrian right
now this is my mom one day i'm talking
to her and i say mom you know everybody
in school is talking about democrats and
republicans what the hell are we i still
don't know what are we my mom's like
nope
you know one day you're going to read
the book karl marx we're democrats is
what we are because democrats are for
the poor
republicans are for the rich you know
what i said i said i want to be a
republican one day mom because i want to
be rich i don't want to be republican i
just want to be rich
and she says no we're for democrats how
much does
messaging repeating it over and over
and over and over and over again get me
to flip to a different side whether i
look at somebody in a good way a bad way
an ugly way
yeah that well repetition as a matter of
fact i've done research on what's called
advertising repetition effects right so
how many times should i repeat ms but by
the way
even for repetition effects there's an
inflection point in other words
repeating a message many times is great
up to a point but then you repeat it
beyond that point
it could backfire against you right so
it's an inverted you
got it but but yes absolutely you're
right that repetition is one of the
central tools in the arsenal of weaponry
that marketers will use now
let me give you a a somewhat fancier
you know cognitive psychology
explanation for why people succumb to
this
so there is a german psychologist by the
name of gerd
gigerenzer who developed a research
stream
called fast and frugal heuristics
heuristics are
our mental shortcuts right it's a
decision rule
that you could deploy rapidly so what's
a fast and frugal heuristic
a fast heuristic is one that you could
deploy very very quickly
and it's frugal in that it is not
cognitively
costly to deploy so and let me give an
example of a faster frugal heuristic
in your wheelhouse of investment and so
on so there is something called the
recognition heuristic which basically
goes as follows
choose that which you recognize so if i
give you two investment portfolios
or an investment portfolio made up of a
bunch of companies
some of the companies i recognize i
recognize coca-cola i recognize ford
but i don't recognize gentech so one
group of people
are going to implement the following
investment strategy a fast and frugal
strategy
simply choose to invest in stocks of
companies that you recognize so that's
one strategy right
it's a very naive one right the other
one
is use all sorts of mathematical
modeling from phds and mathematics from
princeton
to come up with the optimal investment
diversified strategy
guess what the simple fast and frugal
heuristic
performs just as well as the fancy one
in other words there are evolutionary
reasons
when simply deploying a fast and frugal
heuristic works just as well so now
let's link it back to
the repetition stuff most people are
cognitive misers meaning that they are
intellectually lazy i don't want to
spend all my time knowing whether
islam is peaceful or not if barack obama
tells me enough times that
islam is peaceful then i will simply use
that
as a shortcut and then it will make my
world much simpler
you follow what i mean so there is a
cognitive
insight enticement for me
to simply be swayed by a repetitive
message because if
if i if i don't do that i'm going to
have to do the heavy lifting
of actually going out to find out for
myself so for example
if i want to truly found out find out
whether historically the democrats
were the racist ones or not well that's
going to have to force me to actually do
some work whether it be on google or in
the library
screw that why don't i just believe
uncle joe
biden who tells me that no it's the
republicans that are the kkk
white supremacists and that's good
enough for me so i think that
instinct of succumbing to repetition
stems from the fact that most people are
cognitively lazy
by the way the answer that i just gave
not only guaranteed that i will be
invited again on your show it has
guaranteed that i will be the number one
most invited guest on your show
why don't you smoke that i got to tell
you your level of humility is on a whole
different level i mean it's just it's
like
number one most humble guy of all time
i i don't think so and i i wouldn't i i
don't think that
necessarily helps at the highest level
when you want to get your message across
but
go back on that you know we we're having
a debate friends family were sitting
there
and this is the question i'm asking you
know the question is
uh you know things are changing
dramatically
things are really changing you know it's
just oh my gosh we've
never had it like this before okay
have quiet rich people who make their
money create jobs and take care of
people have they been around yes
have con artists rich people who abuse
people take advantage of people
have they always been around yes have
lazy people
who want to be entitled to your wealth
and tell you how unfair it is on why
you're making money have they been
around
yes have people who always you know
look at themselves as the you know you
don't even understand what kind of and
they use
guilt or you know if you only knew how
hard my life was
you would know why i'm not winning
they're always looking for a reason why
they're not have they always been around
yes
have people who sit in the middle and i
say i don't know i kind of agree with
both sides
i don't know if i fully agree that i
don't know but you know what you kind of
make sense have the people in the middle
highways
always been around yes have dictators
always been around yes have arrogance
always been up
what's really changed i mean what has
really changed today are we really
behaviorally
changing that dramatically today versus
100 years ago
200 years ago 500 and if yes how so well
it depends on which
phenomenon you're speaking of i mean on
some things of course
there is a social evolution that happens
where
uh you know i used to i mean i'm
speaking generically i've never smoked
but you know i used to think
that uh smoking was okay because the
pharmaceutical companies told me that
it's healthy to be a smoker
but then i learned through epidemiology
that it's actually not true and so i
altered my behavior so
so it's so there are some things that
are impervious to change
the fact that you and i and probably
every other man who's ever lived prefers
a woman who has an
hourglass figure to a woman who is like
the one you mentioned the heroine chic
the the 90 pound
woman or you know or there is no culture
where men
repeatedly prefer women that look like
male olympic swimmers with broad
shoulders and narrow
or waists that is never going to change
no amount of marketing is ever going to
alter that because that
is such an indelible part of what makes
me
a human that you're not no persuasion is
ever going to change that but on other
things
there is a change right who could have
foreseen the types of intoxicating
addictive power that social media has on
our kids 10 or 15 years ago
today it's probably harder for me to get
my kids to to pry
to pry this cell phone away from my kids
than it is to
to have them uh love me right it's
impossible to get them to get off the
the social media so
so some things are open to change other
things are not and i guess that's
exactly what an evolutionary behavioral
scientist does he tries to
he or she tries to study those things
that are interacting with the
environment versus those things that are
indelible part of our human nature
very cool that's why we need you that's
what we need you around that's what we
need you to keep doing
by the way just just to clarify when i
do all that bombastic grandiose stuff i
am
joking i'm not genuine i'm actually a
very down-to-earth guy
of course listen they're just from you
but you're the kind of guy i would want
to go to dinner
and you know debate topics talk topics
go deeper you're that guy you're the
person
anything i want to be friends with and
just have dinner with you i mean that's
how i judge
in the military you would you would see
who you would get along with like this
it's just a guy i want to be friends
with you this this is the kind of person
you want to have in your life
that's the future can i tell you
something by the way what you just said
means a lot to me and it's very sweet
thank you so much patrick
i tell people so i receive as you might
imagine you know
tons of fan mail and all that the ones
that
mean the most to me or some of the ones
that mean the most are precisely from
military guys
the guy who is the navy seal the guy who
is the special forces who says
you know what we would have wanted you
to be with us
and i don't know maybe it's the machismo
part but i'm like i want to hear from
that guy
not from the stanford professor
smoking the pipe and so i i really
understand what you mean it's
about being in the trenches with guys
that are cool that have your back
i'm all about that now maybe by the way
that comes from the fact that
i was also a very competitive soccer
player so when you're
a competitive soccer player you can't
get offended by every word that someone
says it teaches you to be anti-fragile
you don't wilt away because someone
trash talks you
and so maybe there's also that element
that allows probably someone like you
and i
to to get along and be sympathetic i was
having a conversation with these two
guys who were trying to troll me
and i told the guys is that really the
best you got i said do you realize if
you were in the army
the guys at my unit would destroy you
with the way they would troll you would
emotionally be hiding in a closet for
the rest of your life
you guys got to pick up your trolling
game because you don't have it but
but let me let me go to your latest book
so the parasitic mind
how infectious ideas are killing common
sense
what what infectious ideas today do you
feel
have are creating a lot of momentum and
why right
thank you for uh talking about the
latest book so let me kind of give you
the back the elevator story of the book
and then i will answer your specific
question
so i i argue that contrary to the
current pandemic that we're facing with
covid
we've faced another pandemic for the
past 40 50 years
and in this case the virus is not a
biological virus it's a mind virus
that's why i call these
idea pathogens or parasitic ideas and so
where do these ideas come from so if the
if if we're trying to find out where the
covet virus came from we're not allowed
to say because to say where it comes
from would be racist of course
so uh where do these idea pathogens come
from they all come from the university
ecosystem in other words
as i always remind people it takes
intellectuals and professors to come up
with some of the dumbest ideas
so now i'm going to answer you so what i
do in the book basically is i talk about
all these idea pathogens where they
originate from
what downstream effects they have had on
society and then how we can
vaccinate ourselves against these bad
ideas
so now i answer the question of what are
some examples of these
idea pathogens so probably the grand
daddy of all idea pathogens patrick
is what's called postmodernism so
postmodernism is a framework that
developed in the university environment
which basically purports the following
there are no universal truths there are
no objective truths
we are completely shackled by personal
biases by our
uh subjectivity uh by relativism
so to speak of a universal truth is
silly because there are no such truths
now you could imagine how that's a
complete form of intellectual terrorism
because scientists do wake up every day
thinking that there is a truth to be
discovered out there right now the truth
in science might change right
what was true 300 years ago may no
longer be true today we
update what we consider to be true but
we do operate every day under the
premise that there is something to be
discoverable in the world there are
natural phenomena
that are universally true if i throw you
from a building 50 times
gravity is going to have the exact same
effect 50 times out of 50.
so postmodernism is a deeply
flawed and nihilistic framework because
it actually
takes you down a dead end right
what can you build you can't build
bridges using post-modernism
you can't understand consumer choice
using post-modernism
and so it creates a form of uh
chaos when students are taught all of
this nonsense here i'll give you one or
two other
idea packages and then if you want to
hear more i'll tell you more
social constructivism is another idea
pathogen it purports that
we are all born with empty minds with
equal potentiality
and it's only socialization that made us
who we are so michael jordan
didn't start off his lot in life with a
advantage over patrick it's only because
mama hugged him enough or didn't hug him
enough
that he became the nba star that he is
now it's a very hopeful message right
because
it basically argues that any of our
children could be the next einstein or
the next leader
but it is perfectly rooted in
so each of these idea pathogens that i
described i
argue they start off with a noble cause
but then they metamorphosize
into the murder of truth in the pursuit
of that original noble cause does that
does that make sense
yes it does yes it does so you know what
is your biggest concern
outside obviously your post-modernism
all these others but what is your
biggest concern with the
side effects of what critical race
theory could do to us in the next 12
24 36 months yes so so critical race
theory
stems from one of the idea pathogens
that i discussed in the book so identity
politics
the idea that i am first a member of a
group before i am an individual right
i'm not
god sad i'm lebanese jew first well no
i am gata i present myself on patrick's
show
not as a representative of lebanese jews
i present myself as
god sad with all my flaws and all my
merits and i ask you to judge me based
on my unique personhood that's what
classical liberalism is
well identity politics shatters that it
says you are a member of the lgbt
community or the muslim community or the
black community or the indigenous
community that's what defines you
now i escaped the society
that is a perfect manifestation of how
you organize a society
along identity political lines right
lebanon
everything is viewed through the prism
of your religious
tribe right as a matter of fact in
lebanon there's an arabic word in
well in lebanese that says means
your internal passport your internal id
card so that if the cop stops you
you show him your internal id well the
the most conspicuous thing that you see
on the id
is which religion you belong to right
the constitution of lebanon is organized
along religious lines the president has
to be of this religion
the prime minister has to be of that
religion this is the number of seats
this religion gets in the parliament
so everything is viewed through the
prism of identity political line what do
you end up with
you end up with the lebanese civil war
that's what happens in the balkans
that's what happened in iraq so
everywhere where you create
these tribal factions they might coexist
for a while
but eventually the stressor of this
polit
you know political allegiance to
different groups will start causing
mayhem in the society so
what worries me the most is that the
west
is losing the belt of protection that it
had
because of its very liberating and
enlightened
values each of these are now being
trashed
by all the idea pathogens that i
described in the book so in 10
20 50 years if we continue along the
same lines
we will have a repeat from the beirut
that i escaped in 1975.
so you you asked a couple questions at
the beginning you said
what is the number one reason why uh man
becomes a uh what did you say well a man
becomes a you know you abuse his
children and his own
children is because he had a stepfather
right that's the one you talk about
because the stepfather always treats his
biological sons kids different than he
does his step-children and he said the
second reason why does a
woman end up becoming it or because a
long-term relationship with the man that
they had in their lives because men
you know the jealousy of a woman
cheating on him and fidelity etc etc
okay
so man you know what is the
ultimate thing man is willing to fight
for
i have my opinions i've read a lot of
books on the topic where you think about
hey
when you start a new country what do you
need to have in the country to attract
the best families to come on board
okay you have to think about what a
mother thinks about every morning she
wakes up which is what
are my kids going to be safe so number
one is security right no no
and then you know the creativity of man
what does creativity man need
what do you think is the number one
thing man
is willing to put their lives on the
line that eventually they're gonna be
like listen man
you've crossed the line i'm gonna have
to fight you for this you're gonna have
to kill me to take this away from you
what is that one thing for most of us
i actually discussed this in chapter one
of the parasitic mind where
i'm trying to explain what are the two
life ideals that shape every trajectory
in my life and i came up with two which
answer your question
it's truth and freedom right you can't
pursue truth without freedom
and uh you can't have freedom if you're
constantly murdering truth so they're
kind of
they they it's a feedback loop between
these two now freedom to me means many
different things it's not just
you know freedom of speech which of
course is fundamentally the most
important right
but you know i i try to look at
decisions that i've made in my life
that speak to freedom in completely
different domains so let me give you
another
example when i used to be a competitive
soccer player i played what's called the
playmaker role
in other words i would float around the
field
looking for spaces to try to you know be
creative now if a coach came along
and told me today you're playing more on
the left side of midfield you have to
track back and cover
so you are restricting my freedom
it's as if you had decapitated my head i
lost all my creative juice
so for me so to answer your question in
a very sort of existential way
the most fundamental thing that people
fight for
is for freedom right i mean and security
is ultimately linked to freedom if i
don't have the freedom
to walk outside in new york city without
having a
stray bullet kill me that's not very
good so
freedom is everything the rest is
details
yeah i'm kind of with you there so right
now if freedom is
everything and you are
being pushed today the other day i we
make a video on our podcast we talk
about
an athlete that gave his opinions on a
health matter
and hey whether i want to do this or not
a decision i don't want to take we wrote
it
we read it what he said that video was
flagged it got a strike
channel was shut down for a week and
then channel came back a week later
right and we haven't had a lot of
strikes with our channel our channel was
clear
monetized the whole time we followed the
rules that they have but it makes you
kind of sit there like uh
i don't know if i want to touch this
time just like last week i was at rudy
giuliani's place
all day we interviewed him four hours if
the interview goes live
this is going to get millions on top of
millions of views because what's some of
the things he said
my attorneys are saying don't put it up
because
there's likely if something's going to
happen to your channel if you put up
that specific topic what he said about
that thing that he revealed to everybody
that's going to be controversial is it
good idea that
is it a good idea that we're going in
the direction where we have to wake up
every morning saying i don't know
because some people are given the
argument from the other side well it's
not you know
fact checking is not good if it's not
true if it's not this and how do you
know this and it's not it makes people
think it gives people ideas
how dangerous is the direction we're
going with censorship
i think what the example you gave is
exactly the right point to make because
oftentimes what people say is
well it's not the government that's
stopping you so this has nothing to do
with freedom of speech because
in their imbecilic myopic way they think
that
the attack on freedom only comes from
the government well you just gave an
example
that had nothing to do with the
government you have a unbelievably
successful
youtube channel i i checked it three
million my god i only dream of having
such a reach congratulations
thank you you've worked hard you've done
the right things to to to be an engaging
person to have
a great guest now you have to think
twice do i want to lose all that so what
will you do you'll do
self-censorship right so when the kid in
class
wants to say something that's positive
about trump
he has to decide should i say it in
which case the professor might
grade me down in my grade by the way in
in the parasitic mind i
i i publish anonymously several
bits of letters that i received from
people from students from professors
from paris of students one of which was
exactly this case which is
a student had worked on a paper
scientific paper for a while with his
supervisor
the supervisor found out that the
student had said something
you know mildly positive about trump he
takes his name
off the paper so this wasn't the
government stopping you from speaking
the greatest danger comes from creating
a society
where we will do the bidding of ours of
our attack of
freedom of speech we self-censor right
now i happen to be
someone who for better or worse i'm a
honey badger so i never modulate my and
believe me
i've had a i used to get so many death
threats
that when i would go to campus i had to
be accompanied
by security the university came with me
to the montreal police to file a report
beca and i had to bring a whole dose
here with all the death threats so there
are many costs you have to bear
irrespective of whether it's the
government that's infringing your
freedom of speech
so i really get upset when people say
well so what if youtube
demonetizes you that's not the
government that's not an infringement of
fear and speech
well no because the next time that i
want to put something on covet
i'm going to think twice as to whether
i'm going to say what i feel or not
so i completely agree with you uh what
you
felt is exactly the type of problem that
we need to redress
so that we can truly have a free and
flourishing society
here's what i believe in i believe the
bully doesn't win long term
i believe the bully creates a bigger
bully that whoops his ass in ways that
it hurts them for many many years to
come
that's what i believe in because you
know um
when when i sit with a lot of investment
bankers who invest into different
companies that i have
okay i was with one yesterday in fort
ward and they manage around 28 billion
eight billionaires money 28 billion
dollars one deal we're doing they're
looking at investing with me
so i sit with them and 90 of the
conversation
i crushed it 10 of it i'm like
wow those questions i didn't have an
answer for i got to work on that right
now 10 years ago when i sat with guys
like this
10 of it i crushed it i you know the
other 90
i had no clue what i was talking about
and it didn't lead to a lot of business
so you get better over time but what
happens is when you bully
and you only want to impose one way of
thinking
to an audience who has other ideas
you make their argument stronger because
they get to pick apart every single one
of your argument
and then when they get the voice back
when they get the mic back
that that's not a pretty sight when they
get the mic back so i don't i believe
that the fighters show up i believe in
the sheepdogs i believe in the
guys that eventually wake up and say
yeah that's kind of enough of you
bullying let us kind of really show you
who the real bullies are it's the guys
that sit around quietly who bully
bullies
and we're very good at it it's time to
give that mic back in you can still have
a mic but you cannot bully people moving
forward you can give your ideas but it's
no longer being forced down so
i'm optimistic that what happens long
term is we're going to be taken care of
are you in the same uh belief that
that's eventually going to be taking
place or no
i do so if you're asking me am i
optimistic that we'll be able to address
all these problems i am
otherwise i wouldn't wake up in the
morning with vigor and with a smile on
my face and with hope
you'd be thinking about shaq when you
woke up in the morning you don't want
that
by the way i love that you mentioned
sheepdogs because we have uh we're a
family with belgian shepherds so i don't
know i mean you were a military guy
all of the commandos all have belgian
shepherds but we've had belgian
shepherds before it was cool to be
belgian shepherds and let me tell you
i would rather walk into a tough
neighborhood with a couple of belgian
shepherds than with
you know loaded with guns i mean these
guys are so fierce it's unbelievable
but okay coming back to your question
i am hopeful that there will be an
autocorrective process where those who
are being bullied are going to
rise up the silent majority will speak
out but here's the problem
we can either solve it today peacefully
through dialogue through the battle of
ideas
or we could solve it down the road in a
much more violent way so
so so to go back to critical race theory
that you mentioned earlier
you know people are not going to sit
quietly forever
as their children are being taught in
school
that they suffer from dermatological
original sin as i call it
because their skin you is white right so
we've we've taken the old racism against
black people
which was reprehensible then and we've
cloaked it in the
robe of progressivism today where it is
perfectly okay
to be unbelievably racist to white
children
because you know bruh uh systemic racism
okay
so good peaceful
white people are one day going to wake
up and say i've had enough
now do you want them to wake up
peacefully by attending the parent
teacher meetings or do you want them to
wake up in 40 years and be a lot more
violent the choice is yours that's why
i constantly get engaged because i don't
want to see violence i want to see us
defeating those other idiots
in the battle of ideas here's the
challenge with that though
the challenge with that is that most
people who are in power
believe they will have their power
a lot longer than they usually do they
don't realize that you're eventually
going to lose your power
it's just it's not permanent right sonny
francis who's the father of michael
francis
a an infamous gangster
uh who just died a year and a half ago
at the age of 104
and he goes way back sonny francis
feared feared gangster
back in the days he told his son
something once he said
listen be very respectful to even the
smallest weakest person today because
who's in charge historically changes
who you who reports to you today one day
you may be reporting to them so just be
respectful of everybody whether they
have power they don't have power
unfortunately today the people of power
today don't respect those who don't have
the power today
if they did it'd be a different story
well hence the deplorable argument of
hillary clinton right she thought she
was a shoe-in for the presidency
and so she didn't need to be respectful
to those great
unwashed rubes they were laurables and
then suddenly it came back to haunt her
now rather than her having some humility
and say you know i
actually was a useless candidate who
made some serious faux pas
it was trump it was the russians it was
this she had no humility to recognize
her fault but it speaks to exactly the
point you made
she thought she was guaranteed the power
so she could denigrate those that are
below her
and you know what i like what twitter
did and youtube and facebook did is when
she started making claims
that the election was a fraud when trump
won because of russia it was impressive
to see twitter youtube and facebook
uh to deplatform her i it was very
impressive when that took place with
hillary clinton obviously hence the
sarcasm that never
i was just thinking i was trying to
think is he being sarcastic
because i don't remember her being well
played grasshopper well played
well listen i gotta tell you 90 minutes
went by like it's five minutes i had a
blast with you this was a lot of fun
you are a fantastic guest i appreciate
you for coming out and i'm looking
forward to the next time hopefully next
time it'll be face to face instead of
over soon
i look forward to it brother thank you
so much for having me on it was lots of
fun
anytime and we're going to put the link
below so anybody that wants to go order
his book his link's going to be below
take care
take care bye bye bye i got to tell you
this was one of my favorite interviews
of all time because we were laughing
we were thinking we were going having a
banter
you know i was learning hopefully you
were learning it was just an incredible
conversation dialogue those are my
favorite kind of uh
dialogues that we have and if you
enjoyed this interview there's two other
interviews i want you to watch one of
them
is with jordan peterson where i
interviewed him uh
this has got to be in front of six or
seven thousand people at the same event
where i interviewed president bush and
kobe bryant delay kobe bryant
if you haven't seen that it's very deep
he gets emotional
and this was right before he left for
about a year year and a half i haven't
seen it you gotta watch us
the other one was with daniel lieberman
that was another one that we had a lot
of fun
left we talked about random things so
either one of these you're going to
enjoy click on either one to watch
take care everybody bye